mit m way jeden und alles wusste zur
braucht ist familie schmid abruf
australien
das ist erstmal gut
[Musik]
da vorne links die straße
tour guide im outback und durch events
wie sie es wanderer unterwegs
auch hätte sie ihre familie glück kunde
jetzt refisch mit video
aber mama ganz anderen ort noch
turbulenter york neustart als neues
familienmitglied und jetzt romagna dazu
mit dem umzugsstress
[Musik]
apropos schmid merkt man schnell ruf
schale weicher kern
familie in china und tablets wichtigste
wird auf glück sie härter kämpfen
[Musik]
im raum von vielen die auf der suche ist
dahin
[Musik]
australien was für ein gegensatz zu der
schweiz die endlose weite
das ist wunsch land vor viel freiheit
träumt
ich bin auf dem weg zu der familie
schmid landmann die kreisstraße
überhaupt aber war nie klar ich so live
[Musik]
und dort bieten jetzt oder westküste wo
australien in mary-janes ruhigsten 4670
die wohnung allerdings navi ist mir
wirklich froh dass ich mich erstmals
australien eingetroffen
und hier können nach dem weg frage das
ist es aufs neue die high von dina und
dem cap schmid und irma vier hinter aber
wo ist gott ist noch nicht ganz klar
sassenberg das mira sie die elbestädter
schmitz und das dauert ein paar jona die
zweitjüngste wir sind voller falscher
thüringer aufgebaut wird ist richtig
aber sie funktionieren
ich gratuliere ganz herzlich
also wer fremde ist ein neustart wie
damals vor sieben jahren kaputt macht
sich als erster auf nach australien
die knapp dreijährige amira muss von
ihrem vater abschied der sechs monate
alte rohren ist noch zu klein um zu
verstehen dass sein papier nun voraus
geht um ihr leben auf den kopf zu
stellen
[Musik]
die neue bleibt mit den beiden kindern
noch in ihrem zuhause in sankt
gallischen dorf prof
ob ich denn jetzt
gerufen
also dachte okay
[Musik]
zwei monate später brechen auch die nahm
die kinder auf ein langer flug derzeit
gibt um nachzudenken
die neu erinnert sich an den schlimmsten
moment ihres lebens zwei jahre zuvor
musste sie die tod geburt ihrer zweiten
tochter erleben auch ein grund dass die
familie auswanderte und dann aber
wirklich sehr ernsthaft darüber
nachdenken ob merkel die zitrone jetzt
habe ich es machen immer nur der vorräte
und damit 50 genehme sagen hey warum
haben es nicht macht dann sinn den tisch
gemacht und so busy und fälligkeit
öffnen und sie forschen aber dann
müssten wir mehr ziemlichen probieren
mehr als gut machen während frauen
probieren
endlich ist die familie gefolgt
am flughafen der wüstenstadt alice
springs im zentrum australiens
die nächste größere stadt die 1500
kilometer entfernt
der schweizer hat vor gericht genannt
haben
[Musik]
das gleich mal die heilige
da wurden allerdings die chance straße
als schwieriges finden die fahrer mehr
[Musik]
waters familien ist doch eher spärlich
eingerichtet passend zu den hohen
temperaturen von alice springs geht es
bald 70 zuhörer spiele spiele die
erziehung der kinder bleibt mehrheitlich
die sache von diemer
tablet ist wochenweise im outback
unterwegs als touristenführer
es sind 100 kilometer unbefestigte
straße dass ich erst mal drauf sind dann
investoren helfen und und und
jared gibt sein wissen rund um die
gefahren der australischen wildnis nicht
nur den touristen weiter sondern auch
seiner tochter amira capital tamira
nicht nur schlangen kunde der will auch
zeigen wie man velo fährt
ausgerechnet dabei passierte es cabot
bricht sich die schulter die folgen sind
fatal
durch diesen unfall verliert er seine
anstellung
der traum vom auswandern droht zu
platzen
er wird braucht umgehend einen neuen job
sonst werden er und seine familie aus
geschafft schmieds haben glück damit
kann ein computergeschäft übernehmen
die auftragslage ist gut er kann sogar
arbeiter einstellen
koffer und eine bis vor der familie haus
und techniker der technik für mich gut
und freue mich gibt es nur mehr horbert
umzug
[Musik]
und auch privat läuft es bestens
ihr drittes kind kommt zur welt ein
schwesterchen
[Musik]
rosige zukunft so als schmied schlägt im
auto verhält sich anders vor ausbau
woche 1 ihres geschäftes und sind weg
von alice springs jetzt schon die große
schwester und louisiana
erst vor zwei wochen ist wirklich
schlimm die sache
die ältere schwester amira und bezüger
mit der fußball ist richtig fräulein
wurde
sie ist hin und hergerissen
wenn sie auch zu überdenken
ja
aber damit will für den steht ab 12
ihren bruder rohen herzlich mit
computerspielen ja aber viel wichtiger
sind echte motocross tisch erfahrung mit
nämlich showrennen die axa sa die
chronik ruhig mit 37 12
oktober hat sich chris ihre frau gibt er
beschrieben es mir einfach von oben
verordnet transport und direkt das ich
ein lied art für dina und michael schmid
aber noch ein darsteller auch schnell
wieder gut
familie wird die neue umgebung
auskundschaften
sie können die sehenswürdigkeit besucher
der wave rock für australische
verhältnisse sprung 22 und damit dazu an
den ex prinz pontasch und überall muss
15 stumpf haben und plötzlich heißt
chance dass sich zwei oder drei
richtungen die immo beständig das büro
ist die potter manie bis groß bekommt
man nur bis ca
und wasser
hinweg nicht aus
ausflug ist auch ein test für ca
wenn's und weg sie mit ihrer hütte gott
wenn schmieds mit wohnwagen dürfte
kreisen
die welle forum hat dem fehlt namen wave
rock
picknick
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
diarra zeigt sich von ihrer besten seite
mit scott ina mit ihren bald druck in
job aber der test bestanden
der erste war gefährlichste stadt nie
weg
[Musik]
in erding im familienauto und dennoch
ist der lauf selbst so hoch geklettert
so hoch geklettert wie es nur gegangen
ist
am allerhöchsten amira ist um skype
damit ihre beste freundin sophie trotz
der 2000 kilometer distanz sind sie sich
immer noch spitz mit die nacht aufwache
und völlig vor dem bett lager in mesum
in häufig falsch vom bett aber kate und
menüs sind die büros klappert es in der
future nicht lieferbar absehbarer zeit
sich gedanken gemacht was soll der
scheiß er hat aber gefunden wo das
bringt türkischen aber sie haben es
nicht mehr richtig äußerst zu bringen
mit city thunder das erste musikstück
kostet ob sie es nicht nötig
foto mitglieder naja
und so macht sich auf den weg nach paris
blieb ein anderes übrig fazit
gut zwei stunden weg
wo die bisher letzte mit dem baby will
ich mit dir aber kräftig gewechselt
haben die tiere für die eher
unbeschwerte moment mit der cia sind
schmitz besonders dankbar
angst ums baby ich nämlich einhaltung
sie dass sie von alice springs weg sind
wie man untersuche der schwangerschaft
hatte das jahr einfach nur leid und die
schwerbehinderte darum ein schmied wähle
ich vom kinderspital ziel war es für das
glück dass das jetzt gar nicht braucht
das jahr ganz gut
die ganze angst roman kain wohl dazu
geführt dass die bevölkerung sind immer
möglich klingt jetzt hat sie untersucht
so wie man das regierung sucht aber
natürlich speziell aus der balance will
dir wirklich richtig macht streben noch
nie sorgen wo sich jeder jede ältere
teil macht man das hinter sich haben
übermorgen irgendwie okay wäre wenn es
die luft und dann schaut sie das opfer
hat das recht von anbeginn der
grafenstadt jedes jahr wieder bei dem
hintergedanken und dessen renault mit
ihr hat es einen anderen account
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der teppich und racer in der stadt per
auto im umzugsunternehmen irgendwo in
einer container und lagerhäuser mir in
die psychokiste
naja
kevin schmidt
der australier muss man sich selber teil
verwüstet da fehlt dann kommt so ein
vierrädriges geländefahrzeugen
staubsauger da liegt er auf dem court
strafe muss sein
so stieg apple yoga und direkt und
deutlich aber da merkel die
diplomatische art von ganz verlernt
haushalt erfolgreich zurück erobert
jetzt gott mit einer rock high zu frau
und krieg
wie viele gegen tischer kreis und
tochter zu schicken ist ja die große
schleife die leistung weiter machen
dieses brot wird versprochen michail
prochorow damit so schlimm sei das gar
nicht aus aber ich merke zum ersten mal
die natur sprich als ich als mutter die
ihre suche finden
fertigprodukte und zu kommt sie macht
alles selber und dafür kind nimmt sich
viel zeit dafür dass sie doch an bord
ist und ja sie hatte selbst lieber
gemacht ich glaube sie hat nur
auflockert und dann ist das vergaß sie
mit dem rad
aber mit vier sind ist familie idylle
immer nur verwirrt funke temperament hat
sich aber der bleibt ruhig und
glasfenster fachunterricht und ipad vor
diesem sonntag und ist heimat
ruhiges bild erhält der erde schon
hinter sich zieht zum zug bürger alles
bringt capitals computergeschäft geführt
am anfang ist es gut gelaufen problem
dargestellt das hotel costa sind ganz so
lang macht bis finanzieller familie
eigene geschäfte sprache der capital
schätzt wieder angestellt bin einer
telekommunikationsfirma die zwei woche
verschaffen kind bald wieder los mitteln
und danach von abspielen das ist wie
stark sie und damit sichert weg wie
springsteen eigentlich ziemlich positiv
wenn man sie sind sich ruhig sie sich
nicht mehr
sie sind sich einig sie mag ihre
kollegen aber nicht wirklich alles
spricht aber dass man das mit
seitenblicken so
alice springs ist in speziellen ort dank
ist sie immer sehr gut fand nie wirklich
problemlos hysterisch sein was machen in
alice springs beherzigen dem sportclub
war perez verstehen die freunde und dann
dann geschah alles was brauch ich habe
wirklich so stimme bis machen es hat mit
ja das hat ja machen sich das gar nicht
vorstellen
die schweiz war und an seinem forschen
stunde und beim biss in zürich oder
beschwerden aber beschieden war bis kurz
danach erschien zu oder eine party oder
es hat einfach nicht in diese mieten
nur noch als baumethoden shepherd wieder
die hi wo sie lebten glücklich macht ist
[Musik]
ihnen aus doch vor als prinz aus g-20
bei hirsch buch was immer man es zum
start flug gebucht dem herrn größte
starb zuge der kiste die eco mode und
richtig man sich genau der grund das ist
freundlich mit gar nicht alles so
schnell gegangen
wir haben die mir welle und der einzige
krone wo ist nur der rechte hat ist das
mit dem ring sie ist mir ganz wichtig
sie objekte was in ordnung ist das auch
nicht verteidigen
kurz kinderspital nach vorheriger schock
löste so weit wie labour kriminalität
ist jede baugebiets lebensqualität und
der zauber nach sonnenuntergang nämlich
gar nicht dass nicht nur frustrierend
oder er hat so viel investiert und
anschlussstelle jahr waren es plötzlich
so will habe sagte wasmuth haben ich
glaube nicht dass man es falsch gemacht
haben die hanse schwierigen ort probiert
wo sich möglichkeit hat den 7
nein mir gar nie dank dass das rein das
einzige wofür diese unterscheidet form
nicht dass familie csr und die
erkenntnis sehnsucht nach einer
funktionierenden der familie mit der
familie wieder da ist
zum die jungen vorzeige produkt also ich
mich ins rund 1000 familien wo sie
vorhanden ist und später an größere
familie größer
traditionell ging von der familie
vermisst hat
ich reiche stadt passt was diener
haltlos alice springs
sie hätte der letzte tanz als pole dance
fitness studio aus dem boden gestampft
und zum aufgebracht und ihrer fahren das
ist gerade biomechanisch aus hundesport
sport genauer dance music city meine
zeit diener und sein studio facebook ist
für ein studio das sind jetzt findet sie
das konto flexibilität sehr wichtig
krafttraining ist sehr wichtig dann
haben wir eben die maschine kam aus
einer hand irgendwann mit dem machen
ganz bestimmt war überaus thomas bäumer
kraftsport kraft und beweglichkeit ja
das competitions gemacht ein extrem
süchtig machen das ist so das gefühl man
muss wirklich alles sauber erklärt ich
habe diese privat stunden unterricht ist
youtube selber gibt aber kein youtube
selber gibt am psi kriegt einfach
stundenlang nur
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dina ist so bischof blätter und hat mich
gemacht
[Musik]
die depression aber durchaus gestolpert
ist hier wirklich gut genug wenn ich
sage ich bin hab ich viel mehr schwach
die zertifizierte und er hat
wahrscheinlich gemerkt
motivation ist irgendwie das gefühl hat
sie das gern machen und ich kann sagen
was sie überhaupt nichts und ich denke
es hat also ich effektiv viele jahre
überhaupt nicht lustig sie wo das
passiert mir dank dass das so langsam
ist und nach
aber wenn du mit dem zusammen so bei mir
und du denkst du kannst die person und
denke dass ich das gut
plötzlich um zwei täter plötzlich nicht
mehr wieder und darum stand immer
schlimmeren verloren und das hat uns am
rand vom familienglück brauchen das
strandleben morgenmagazin
ich bin darüber hinweg und ich bin der
externe texte und vater ich bin jetzt
total sexy wie sie dass das ist für eine
kapazität hat zu den tieren nie richtig
weggekommen und egal was man gemacht
wir sind ja unter uv strahlen wie dem
bag vor allem da ist es doch immer
wieder hoch und das mitmachen machen ist
es egal ob es das andere
irgendwann untersuchung also wirklich
einen aufbruch familie hinter mir klar
aber country chips für mich gemacht
durch ihre diener und kevin schmid
erhielt iris rucksack rühren sie mitleid
aber unterdessen ist vergangenheit nur
schwer zu träge
der australier harry heimatkunde da sind
sich sicher ob inzwischen hat familie
sogar der australischen pass wir sehen
jetzt will sie sieht sondern strahle sie
und für mich und den abfahrts
enttäuschung
integriert und wann trinken hilft ohne
den fluss ohne das heißt hier sind die
sich für australien gehört sind sehr
stolze besitzer von wohnwagen und
erklärt wenn es bald mit der ganzen
familie des größten kunden hatte aber
noch nicht ausprobiert
euro gedacht
bewohnbar gebrauchte zum buchen motto
große
coventry abgewandt sind dann freuen
apa
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vorangegangen war
[Musik]
jetzt ist es so still und zurückhaltend
zeigte sich von ganz anderer seite
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so und spielen nach
[Musik]
angst um der junioren jetzt kann's
losgehen
die erste serie aus sechsköpfige familie
das sind schmieds neue die who wieder
aufbrechen unterwegs ins konzept der
familie schmid
sie wählen die ried mit einer hand voll
auskosten
vielleicht nicht zuletzt will sie müsse
das leben selbst endlich ist sondern bis
zum boxsport
[Musik]
nächste woche bin ich in lima wieder
familie wettstein wie gott sie mit sechs
jahren auswanderer jedenfalls gelernt
sich die großstadt wärme bier zu sehen
ordnung sind
[Musik]
mit m way jedem sie bei und alles wusste
zur tracht punkt ch